I was speaking at a conference today and
playing on one of the guys was so
worried about the fact that they may
lose their job and I said listen there's
one thing you can do to be
recession-proof forever I don't know
what's going on you will always be
recession-proof if you learn how to do
this
it ain't no certificate that ain't no
degree it ain't on likely on nothing
it's learning how to sell the moment you
learn how to sell you are officially
recession proof let me explain to you
why your recession if the market is
doing good there's companies that always
need people that know how to sell if the
country is doing bad if the economy is
doing that banks needs people that'll
sell people on keeping their homes and
modifying their homes regardless of what
it is instead of spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars trying to get
another degree or another certificate
learn how to sell you will be recession
proof your income will be recession
proof for the rest of your life cause
you know how to sell and large
corporations and industries always have
a need for great salespeople chlorin how
to sell to be recession proof a promise
[Music]